And with that, that's going to wrap it up for this tutorial series about how to utilize
liquid inside of Niagara with the Niagara Fluids plugin.
Real quickly to recap what we did today, we first started out by going over the Niagara
Fluids overview, just covering what Niagara Fluids is and what you can create with the
system.
We then took a look at enabling the Niagara Fluids plugin, how to enable that inside of
the editor, where to find it, and also make sure to restart once you have enabled it.
We then talked about the Niagara Fluid content example, which is a great map in the content
example collection that shows you how to use all of the various Niagara liquids as well
as features such as collision, multicolored smoke, and other various bits of interaction.
We then moved on to creating 2D smoke, liquid, and fire effects, followed up by creating
the 3D version of smoke, liquid, and fire effects.
And finally, we finished up looking at how we can optimize our smoke, liquid, and fire
effects using the Baker inside of Niagara to bake our complex Niagara liquids to a series
of still images that allow them to be played back, mimicking that real time behavior.
Well, that's all that I have for you.
Again, my name is Sam Dider.
I'm a senior Unreal Engine instructor, and I will see you next time.